Today we are going to take ChatGPT and it will
be given a stern talking to. Yes, we will try
to help it to learn from its own mistakes and
do better. Can it? Well, let’s see together.
But first and foremost, how do we do
this? Well, these large language model
assistants can typically be improved from
the inside by reprogramming them. However,
not in this paper. Here is a crazy idea -
let’s try to improve it by reprogramming it,
from the outside the instead. With
linguistic feedback. Yes, get this,
it will get a stern talking to. Now I hear you
asking, Doctor, that is crazy - how do we do that?
Well, here is an example. First, we
ask it a history question. And we
get an answer that is incorrect. Now we
ask the AI to reflect on its mistakes,
and now it learns that the answer
should have been a series of wars,
not just one war. And now, with this in mind,
we can ask it again, and bam, there we go.
This concept works for decision making,
programming, and reasoning style questions
as well. That is fantastic. But, how much of an
improvement can we expect using this technique?
Well, when running OpenAI’s HumanEval dataset,
which is a test with more than 150 programming
problems. These problems are hand-written
to make sure the AI cannot have seen these
problems before. So, how does it do? Whoa! Look
at that. Suddenly it is now the best performing
AI model. We go from 80% to 91% accuracy. That
is a huge improvement, if this were GPT4.5, that
would have been a reasonable result. And we didn’t
need to pop the hood, but all we needed to do here
is ask it nicely to essentially write a journal
and learn from past mistakes. How cool is that?
In his amazing science fiction novels,
Isaac Asimov wrote about robopsychologists,
scientists who were called when a robot was
malfunctioning to find out what is going on in the
brain of this little AI. And he wrote this about
73 years ago. And today, here we are. The first
robopsychologists are appearing in our real world.
How incredible is that? What a time to be alive!
Now, in the meantime, ChatGPT and GPT-4 also have
some new, really cool applications. For instance,
I was stunned to find out that not everyone of
you Fellow Scholars know or use Code Interpreter,
now also known as Advanced Data Analysis. This can
use Python programming to solve your
tasks, and even takes file uploads.
I love seeing how diligently it writes code
when I ask it something, this is a super simple
example of Monte Carlo integration. My job here
is essentially to direct the work of this little
AI and make sure to check it thoroughly. Or,
wait a second…what if I just ask it to test
itself? It gives some nice proposals for me to
do. Wait a second…how about you do all of these,
little AI? And…I am absolutely loving how it
is going to town and checks the validity of
its solutions from several different angles. We
even get a beautiful little plot of this classic
experiment. This tool is an absolute powerhouse
and I feel that as it improves, programming
computers will be available for everyone in
the world. Loving it! This is just incredible.
And, don’t forget, this can take files from
us, and it can also give files back to us,
transformed. Thus, we can even ask it for
a little movie editing, or you can upload
your favorite Spotify playlist for it to
analyze. It undergoes statistical analysis,
and if you like explanations better
than visualizations and bar charts,
you can even ask it to explain all this
in plain English. How cool is that? Wow.
So, as you see, ChatGPT has
hasn’t even been out for a year,
and it has improved leaps and bounds. You can have
this incredible intelligence trained on almost
the whole internet, right at your fingertips.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!